[Music]  in this peaceful town on these quiet  streets something terrifying something  horrifying  is coming excuse me we're closed  what the hell was a wild animal this is  really awful maybe the worst thing I've  ever seen  well was it wild animals so what are you  thinking I'm thinking zombies y-you know  the undead ghouls you gorgeous oh my are  you in this together flesh-eating  zombies don't joke it's really really  creepy  Oh oh man this isn't gonna end well they  gravitate towards things they did when  they were alive called pee did she just  say Chardonnay yeah she did  welcome to my world are these I've been  telling you this is all gonna end badly  well that's unfortunate I'm quite  confident of my ability to defend myself  against the undead I can see that  excuse me those are some pretty good  cuts he played some minor league ball  didn't you  well a little clase he was a long time  ago  [Music]